Did you know that the border gateway protocol,
BGP,
is the magic incantation
that you need to deliver services
at the edge?
Well, you don't need to be a wizard
to understand this today. Let's imagine you want
some McNuggets.
You know there's at least 30 or maybe
90 McDonald's within a quarter mile of wherever
you are. But which one is closest?
Unless you know, you may use Google Maps
to help you out. It knows where you
are,
and it knows where all the McDonald's are.
It can give you the quickest route from
a to b. BGP is the Google Maps
of the Internet.
It doesn't matter where you are
or where your customers are.
With the power of the Internet, they can
always access your website or your product.
It may just take them a little bit
longer if they're further away from where your
servers or your applications are hosted.
So to minimize that latency,
you start deploying
to multiple regions or even to edge locations.
But now you've got six or 12 points
of presence, but you still got a challenge.
You still got a problem to solve.
How do you route your customers wherever they
are
to your POP in the right region
with the closest path?
Now you can use BGP
to do this. It provides the ability to
have a single IP address and allow BGP
to advertise different routes in different regions,
much in the same way that Google Maps
will route you from where you are to
the nearest McDonald's.
Now to do this, all you need is
more points of presence, more pops,
at least ten years of networking excellence,
enough money to buy some IP v four
pills, your own autonomous systems, and even more
money to bribe the other autonomous systems to
peer review. Breaking news. Ngrok's global load balancers
provide everything you need to deliver low latency
services around the world with eight POPs including
Asia, Australia, India, South America,
and of course, America and Europe.
Ngrok will handle the routing of requests to
your edge services
for you.
Wow.
You don't even need to geo replicate your
application to take advantage of lower latency due
to ngrok's connection and module acceleration capabilities.
Double wow.
To sweeten the deal, if any of your
edge locations are failing,
ngrok will route requests for your service to
the next closest edge.
You're welcome. Get started with ngrok's global server
load balancer today and keep your customers happy.
Link to get started in the description below.
Now back to the studio.
Alright.
That's enough of the whimsical.
Let's dive into the fun and get hands
on keyboard.
Here you will see I have four panes
open in my terminal, two in The EU,
Two in The US.
This is the simplest Deno application I can
put together where this one says hello EU
and on the bottom
it says hello US.
We can run both of these applications,
and we could hit them on the public
IP of each machine itself. However, we want
to use ngrok and the global load balancer.
For that, I can run ngrok tunnel passing
on a label I got from the ngrok
UI like so.
I can do the same in The US.
We can then head over to these tabs
where I can do a curl from The
US box, and we get hello US.
From my local machine, I get hello EU.
Let's shut down The US tunnel,
and now we get hello from EU.
It really is that simple. Anyone can undo
it. Go check out ngrok.com
today.